[Music]
the rich don't always get richer as a
group The 400 wealthiest Americans are
worth 4 trillion dollars 500 billion
dollars less than last year
the minimum net worth to make the Forbes
400 this year dropped for the first time
since the Great Recession down 200
million dollars to 2.7 billion dollars
amid the market sell-off at number five
is Warren Buffett worth 97 billion
dollars in March Buffett's Berkshire
Hathaway agreed to Shell out 11.6
billion dollars for insurer Allegheny
Corp in April he told investors he had
put 51 billion dollars of berkshire's
cash in the stocks including billion
dollar bets on Chevron Occidental
Petroleum and HP one of the biggest
philanthropists in history Buffett
continued his summer tradition of
donating billions to charity giving
shares worth about 4 billion dollars to
The Gates Foundation as well as the
foundation's first three children and
late wife in June
at number four is Larry Ellison worth
101 billion dollars Ellison who
contributed 1 billion dollars to Elon
musk's Twitter bid has reportedly been
subpoenaed by Twitter in a messy legal
battle over the deal the Oracle founder
also made news in May when it was
revealed that he joined the November
2020 conference call to discuss ways to
overturn Donald Trump's election loss
at number three is Bill Gates worth 106
billion dollars in July Gates announced
he was shifting 20 billion dollars of
his fortune to the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation that big gift accounts
for most of the estimated 28 billion
dollar drop in his net worth over the
past year Gates who saw an outbreak like
covid-19 coming back in 2015 released a
new book in May how to prevent the next
pandemic at number two is Jeff Bezos
worth 151 billion dollars knocked from
the top spot for the first time since
2017 the Amazon founder and chairman saw
his net worth drop 50 billion dollars as
the e-commerce giant shares tumbled more
than 20 percent through his VC firm he's
invested in everything from digital
media company overtime Sports to Wild
type which makes Seafood from fish cells
meanwhile Bezos ordered a super yacht so
big that shipmaker oceanco had to
request that a historic bridge in
Rotterdam beat the mantled in order for
the vessel to leave
the yacht which is on the verge of
completion was eventually towed away
after intense backlash with the bridge
still intact
number one is Elon Musk worth 251
billion dollars musk tops the Forbes 400
for the first time thanks to a fresh
round of funding for his private rocket
business SpaceX valuing it at 127
billion dollars and an 11 climb in the
value of Tesla stock that's despite a 20
drop in the electric car Maker's share
since musk announced his 44 billion
dollar takeover of Twitter in April
which he's been fighting to void last
November he became the first person
worth 300 billion dollars
[Music]